while the steam deck certainly wasn't
the first device in the handheld PC
category to hit the market it was
undoubtedly the first to have a broad
appeal mainly thanks to its price
undercutting the competition by a
significant margin since then even more
handheld PCS have hit store shelves but
only one has really posed a threat to
the steam deck's dominance the Asus Rog
Ally after some time with both devices I
have found that for all their
similarities on the surface each feels
quite different during use while there
are a select few differences that might
be deal breakers for those seeking
specific features for my money I believe
there's one determining factor in
whether you should pick one over the
other their ease of use but before we
get to that let's talk about those
potential deal breakers while both
devices feature a similar form factor
the Ally has a smaller profile however
it's not so big a difference that I
believe it to be substantially more
portable than the deck the deck is more
rounded in a way that is designed to
fill out your hands the Ally has more
edges with the design intended for you
to rest your palms on its angled Corners
personally I think the deck is more
comfortable and its ergonomic design
better distributes its additional 69
grams in comparison to the Ally that
being said reviewers that have used both
devices have given preference to the
Ally in terms of convert so this is
going to differ depending on the user
something that I don't think will differ
based on user preference is nearly all
the other differentiating Hardware
factors the steam deck is Superior in
several sectors the Ally space buttons
are straight up poor they may be bigger
than the steam decks but they are way
too mushy when you press one of the
decks buttons you're getting a
consistent tactile feel the Ally eyes
buttons are much spongier and therefore
inconsistent to the touch the tension on
Steam deck's thumbsticks is far superior
and comparable to what you would
experience with one of the console
controllers while I don't think the
Allies thumbsticks are nearly as bad as
say joy-cons since they have full range
of motion they still lack the Precision
and smoothness necessary and their
severe resistance deficiency makes them
feel rather flimsy track pads the Ally
doesn't have them but they're one of the
best hardware features on the steam deck
not only are they a great way to
navigate the UI especially in desktop
mode but they make games that are better
suited to Mouse input such as XCOM far
more friendly to play on the device
the steam deck has two dedicated volume
buttons along the top of the device
toward the left hand side the Ally has a
volume rocker more toward the Middle
with the former it's easy to slide your
hand up and press the buttons while
still keeping somewhat of a grip on the
device with the latter you need to take
your hand off the device in order to
press them it's something that seems
like a minute nitpick but its small
design differences such as these that
make for a more pleasant long-term
experience this one is maybe more a
matter of opinion than the other
physical elements but I'm much more fan
of the steam decks cross d-pad than the
Ally circular one
the Ally has the leg up over the steam
deck in a few areas design wise however
triggers and bumpers I much prefer what
the Ally is packing in this department
compared to the deck the triggers offer
the right amount of resistance and the
bumpers are substantial with a
satisfying click to them on the steam
deck the triggers don't provide enough
resistance comparatively and the bumpers
that are flush with the top of the
device not only offer little in feedback
but are far too easy to accidentally
press in with the side of your finger
when attempting to press a trigger
instead I do wish the Ally was able to
match the four back paddles that are on
the steam deck rather than just the two
as they are a feature I utilize often
that being said the ones in the Ally are
designed better offering improved
response and they match the curve of
your fingers when resting on them rather
than forcing you to grip the device as
firmly on the steam deck while the steam
deck has fantastic speakers to my ears
not only do the Allies get louder but
they offer a better more full sounding
range screen this is where the Ally
truly outshines the steam deck and this
is ultimately probably the most
important Hardware feature not only is
it a higher resolution at 1080p compared
to the steamedex 800p but it Sports a
120 hertz refresh rate as opposed to the
steamed x 60 hertz combined with the
fact that the Ally uses an IPS panel for
better colors everything looks and feels
way better especially when moving
through the software and using the
touchscreen feels way more precise
but also helps give the Rog Ally The
Edge on performance is amd's new Z1
extreme which is the chip that is doing
all the processing on the device it's a
substantial increase in performance over
what is packed into the steam deck at
least the model that's available is
later this year a cheaper Ally with a
standard Z1 will be released which is a
chip closer in Spec to the steam deck
but right now the 700 Ally that's
available even compared to steam deck's
most expensive offering at 650 kind of
blows it out of the water from Pure
Performance particularly if you haven't
Plugged In which allows for a high
performance mode since you're not solely
relying on your battery the steam deck
doesn't have any kind of performance
boosting feature when plugging it in
still even unplugged the Allies
performance increase is noticeable and
thankfully when you do want to plug in
the Allies power supply has a much
longer cable than the decks one area
where the deck beats out the Ally in
terms of performance is in lower power
States cranking both devices down to
their lowest battery consumption options
the deck seems to perform on par or even
better in many cases than the Ally if
you're truly intending to do a lot of
traveling with one of these devices and
believe you will frequently be without
an opportunity to charge them the steam
deck has an edge in this category of
getting more bang for your buck out of
its battery on the software side that's
where the Ally and steam deck diverge
even further the former uses plain old
windows 11 out of the box while the
steam deck by default runs on its custom
Linux based Steam OS that means that a
selection of games are unplayable
whether it be titles that use certain
anti-cheat software or ones that simply
don't play nice with proton which is the
compatibility layer of the steam deck
that allows it to play Windows Titles
since the Ally runs Windows not only can
It play essentially at every game
available through Steam but it can take
advantage of services such as Xbox game
pass and run those games natively rather
than only over the cloud as is your only
option with the service on Steam OS it's
been awesome to be able to jump into a
round of Call of Duty Warzone or pick up
where I left off in the lies of P demo
from my XBox if you're a big multiplayer
gamer or take advantage of Xbox game
pass regularly the Ally might be the
better device for you however the single
factor that I think should determine
whether or not you can choose an ally
over the steam deck like I said in the
beginning is ease of use yes you can buy
a steam deck and install Windows 11 on
it no problem but part of the appeal of
the device even though it doesn't allow
for every game to be playable is Steam
OS it creates a much simpler
console-like experience and combined
with steam deck's compatibility ratings
makes it easy to understand what can be
played blade and when you go to play
those games they work as intended the
same cannot be said for the Ally in
Windows 11 which has provided more
headaches during the limited time I've
had with the device than in the months
I've had with the steam deck simply put
the quirks of Windows 11 are exacerbated
by the Allies form factor for example I
installed Call of Duty Warzone initially
via Battlenet but I just couldn't get it
to run smoothly and it's stuck on four
percent Shader compiling and then tried
installing it via steam but for some
reason my right stick wouldn't work
after looking for a solution online it
turns out this is an issue with Warzone
on Steam in general not just on the Ally
and while the solution was easy enough
to execute having to do so restricting
to touch and control inputs made it much
more cumbersome than doing so on a PC
would have yes I could have hooked up a
keyboard and mouse on the device but
that's hardly a convenient solution not
to mentioned not something that would
really be possible if I was on the go
like on a more traditional PC however
steam is still the friendliest software
to use on the Ally booting up the Xbox
app to play games through my game pass
subscription has produced a number of
challenges whether it be games not
booting up when I tap on them to play or
they do actually boot up but somehow
somewhere remain hidden sometimes the
time from turning on your ally to
playing a title via Xbox game pass takes
much longer than you would hope put
simply while the steam deck might be
more limited on what games you can and
cannot play the games that fall into the
former category have significantly fewer
barriers in the way to get them up and
running well in comparison to the Ally
while Asus does have its own layer of
software it calls Armory crate that is
designed to give a steamos like
experience it absolutely pales in
comparison from issues of a not loading
to not keeping up to date on which games
you have installed to just generally
being much harder to use and decipher
than what steam offers you're better off
really not using it it doesn't even have
a way to shut down a game which you're
playing which feels like should be a
fundamental feature to the software
honestly whether the Ally becomes a more
user-friendly device doesn't just rely
on asus's ability to improve its
software features it also in a large
part depends on whether Microsoft makes
a version of Windows that plays nicely
with these kinds of products which we
already know there has been some
internal testing on making a handheld
gaming interface at the company even
still I think ultimately steam's
approach to making a bespoke operating
system designed from the ground up for
the deck is always going to trance
slapping the normal Windows OS onto a
handheld device time will tell how much
a gaming handheld focused version of
Windows would improve the experience if
you're a power PC user and you're okay
with needing to frequently troubleshoot
the quirks of the Ally Then the device
has a few key elements on offer that the
steam deck simply cannot match but for
everyone else especially those dipping
their toes into the PC gaming world for
the first time the usability of valve's
handheld is worth the trade-off
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]